the same thing but it goes back to when
I was fighting when I was younger it was
just like you had to deal with the
nervousness yeah butterflies people
looking at you all the tension from
those moments and and you have to
perform and all that stuff's got nothing
to do with all the time you put in
training and working and everything to
get up to that point you still have to
perform even though all little things
are going on so you have to learn how to
temper yourself and deal with all of
those things you know that I happening
around you and it's you know they're not
the same thing but you can take the same
level of discipline and mine state and I
kind of handle that with directing with
the questions that come hey is this okay
they're all the questions that you get
as a director you know and the
nervousness you know money is at stake I
don't have a lot of money so when I put
in my time on the on the week to get
that shoe it is making a bus baby
because I don't know if I can come back
and do it again so it's make it happen
and you know i I've always been nervous
every single time but I just remember
being really excited and I look forward
to the next chance to be nervous like
that again okay
you